- Hi, I'm Malia. I'm 15 years old.
- Hi, I'm Katie and I am much older still.
And today we are competing once again.
- And here are the rules
for today's competition.
- Number one, you must make an entree.
- Number two, you must make a dessert.
- And number three, it must
be something you would serve
at a fancy dinner party for influencers.
Are you taller than me now?
Are you?
Yes.
Last time, it was a
lot of fun, but I lost.
And I'm really competitive
and I like to win.
But I did have a really
good time with Malia.
I feel like we became friends.
It was a tough loss.
Well, she was 12, so it did hurt
but she was also on Master Chef.
- Hi, I'm Malia Brauer.
I was a former contestant on
Master Chef Junior Season 7.
And I'm so excited to be
competing again with Katie.
The last two and a half years
have totally been life-changing.
I mean, I've gone on
three Master Chef tours
which have been really keeping me busy.
Sometimes I could be gone
for six to seven weeks.
- I have not been traveling.
Been just mostly indoors.
Mostly drinking and
making sourdough bread.
- I love dance.
So I do studio dance and
I do high school dance.
- I think Malia has been having a glow up.
- I mean, Katie last time
was absolutely incredible
but I definitely sharpened
up my knives in the kitchen.
- I feel like my pastry
skills have evolved
over the last couple years
cause I've been doing a lot of desserts.
I think I'm definitely a
better chef than I used to be.
We'll use chef loosely.
- I do wanna win.
I wanna win so bad.
- I don't need to win, but I need to win.
You have a lot of stuff.
- Yeah.
I'm blooming some gelatin.
- My first step is I'm
just creaming some sugar
and some butter.
- So you've been touring with Master Chef.
- Yeah.
- So like have you been just
been like practicing every day
all your culinary skills?
- You're cooking every single day.
- For six weeks?
- For six weeks.
- My next step I am going to
be combining some buttermilk,
a heavy whipping cream,
some Greek yogurt,
some ube extract.
It's the flavoring of the purple yam
that's grown in the Philippines.
That is delicious.
- I'm gonna cream this together,
adding in a singular egg
yolk and some vanilla.
And what I like to say
is you could literally
never have too much vanilla.
Baking soda,
and baking powder into my flour,
and give it a quick little whisk.
- It's crazy how quickly you've grown up.
But you were always a little bit grown up.
Like you're always mature.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna add some heavy cream,
my gelatin,
some honey.
- I love honey
- And some sugar.
- I'm going to be putting my
flour mixture into this bowl.
- So what is it like
performing in front of a crowd?
Do they clap? Do you get standing?
I cook in my house.
There's no cheering.
- I'll come cheer for you.
- You'll come cheer?
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
Do you have friends
over and cook with them?
- Back in my prime time in middle school,
I used to make cookies for everybody.
Well, they'd have to pay for it.
- [Producer] How old were
you during your prime?
- I was 12 years old
- At 12 years old.
- Yeah.
I was in a pony club.
- Slay.
Right now just getting a little glob,
kind of making it into like a ball,
smash it on in there with my knuckle.
- Are there sugar cookies?
- Yeah. You would only
use like an actual crust
but I just find that takes a lot longer.
And I also like the taste
of the sugar cookie better.
- Well, I'm just going to slowly
incorporate my warm mixture
into my ube mixture.
I'm going really slow with my whisk
cause I'm trying not to
incorporate too many air bubbles.
Cause I want it to be nice and smooth.
Is there anything that
you've been getting into
during the last two years
that I should know about?
Any hobbies?
- Yeah.
Well, I have been going to Vegas a lot.
- What are you doing in Vegas?
- Burning it up.
(Katie laughing)
- I'm gonna put this
through a mesh strainer
just to get out any clumps.
Just wanna make sure it's nice and smooth.
- After these are done, just like this,
I'm gonna put them in the oven
for around 8 to 10 minutes
or until they get golden brown.
- I'm gonna were my mixture
into some hoop glasses.
- Super pretty so far.
- If I get your approval,
I feel very good.
Chill these in the fridge.
So what do you do in Vegas?
- We're normally there for just
like a short period of time.
- Okay.
- Like three days or something for dance.
- More than three days
in Vegas is a long time.
- We'll stay the day in Vegas.
Lot to brunch.
- I was not doing that at 15.
15 I was like, "Can we
rent a blockbuster movie?"
And I was like gonna be exciting.
- Mixed together my powdered sugar,
put my cream cheese right in there.
Mix it up.
So Katie, do you go to Vegas a lot?
- No. I've been a couple times.
I love the penny slots.
I am not finishing my dessert
but I need to get some pork marinated.
Okay.
(Katie laughing)
- Good job.
- Good job (laughs).
- Luckily, I just cleaned my surface.
I think I've been cleaner
than the last time.
- Oh yeah, definitely.
I love having a clean space.
- So in this marinade I've
achiote paste, chili powder,
garlic powder, salt, pepper,
cumin, oregano, vinegar,
and some pineapple juice.
- Gonna add in some vanilla
and some lemon extract.
And I love adding lemon extract
because you could barely taste
it, but it just adds so much.
- So now I'm gonna add in some
pork shoulder about a pound.
- Cool.
- And let that marinate
for as long as I can.
- I've done the crust, my
filling for my dessert.
And now I'm just gonna cut up some decor.
So like some strawberries, some kiwis.
- I've made my like filling
or like the main part of my dessert.
But now I'm doing, working
on some toppings for that.
And I've also marinated
some pork for my entree.
I wonder what you're
making for your entree.
- Beware.
- I'm kidding.
So for my topping,
I'm gonna combine some flour, brown sugar,
some oats, some butter,
and I think I'll do a whole pinch of salt.
I've taken my mixture and I've
spread it all over my tray.
- What influencers would
like would be at this party?
- Could an influencer be like
- Like a celebrity?
- Yeah.
- [Producer] Yeah.
- Obviously, I'd invite invite Drake.
- Oh, should we have Beyonce there?
- It is my love.
Oh.
- Beyonce should be there.
Yeah. Okay. Okay.
That's like a mutual invite from us.
- And at my studio,
somebody's actually
doing Hold Up by Beyonce.
Not in that dance,
but it's like literally one
of my favorite dances ever.
- I took tap dance in college.
- Nice.
- Which you wanna see?
- Yes I do.
- Okay.
(shoes clicking)
- Ooh
- Yeah. How did I do?
- I would say use energy with your arms,
through our fingers.
- Through your finger.
Like coming out of your arm.
- That.
- Yeah.
- Out.
Yeah. That's right.
Hop, flip.
(shoes clicking)
That took me like three weeks to learn.
So now I'm just cutting my kiwi.
Chop it in quarters.
- I'm gonna do some petite little slices.
Do you know Gordon Ramsey?
- Yes.
- Okay.
Does he yell at people in real life?
- He will yell at you if you suck.
So here, do want me to feed you?
- Oh my god.
(Katie talking gibberish)
- Sure.
- That's a perfectly right kiwi.
- I know.
So I'm just gonna put these in
the fridge to let them cool.
Now I'm gonna just start
cooking my potatoes.
- Add some sugar on top,
and that's just gonna draw out
the juices and sweeten it up.
So I have Chambord,
which is basically like
a black raspberry liquor.
- Do you wanna try the Chambord?
- I mean, I can drink a little Chambord.
Ooh. Yeah.
- Katie's off to a pretty good start.
- Well, you inspired me last
time we cooked together.
I was like, I gotta up my game for a more.
I gotta have some more elements.
- And you inspired me.
- I'm gonna go put this in the oven
for about 20 to 25 minutes.
And I'm gonna put this in the fridge.
- These entrees are like super important.
So now I'm gonna make my
fig and cranberry sauce.
So I'm just going to be adding Port wine.
We're gonna add in some brown
sugar, some black pepper,
fig spread, you could use fig jelly,
balsamic vinegar,
and then I'm gonna give it a little stir.
And then after that, I'll
add in the beef stock.
- That sounds really fancy and delicious.
I'm going to put this
into a pressure cooker,
and we're gonna make sure
all of our marinade goes in with it.
And then I'm gonna add some pineapple,
guajillo chili pepper,
a little bit of my favorite salsa
which is like a peach pineapple
salsa that's a little sweet.
Just to add more moisture in there.
Make sure we don't burn the
bottom of the pressure cooker.
- I love pineapple.
- Me too.
- Okay. I feel like we
need to go out to dinner.
Like we like a lot of the same things.
- Nobu's, seven o'clock, Saturday night?
- Oh my god. Fancy.
- I'm just kidding.
- I'm there though. I'm there.
Are you paying?
- Tasty will pay.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- How bout that?
- Tasty.
- Yeah. Adding my cranberries
and setting it to low heat.
So now I just drain these potatoes.
I cut them in quarters
and you want them to be
really nice and soft.
Add nice, generous pinch
of salt, light cream,
and then so some Fontina cheese.
- I'm just gonna put this
lid on the pressure cooker.
Cook this on high for 25 minutes.
Now I'm gonna quick
pickle some red onions.
I'm gonna add some
Serrano peppers for heat.
- Now these are all mashed up.
So just gonna set them aside.
- I just wanna whisk together
the oil and the vinegar a little bit.
My vinegar-olive oil mixture is boiling.
I'm gonna just pour that over my onions,
and just gonna mix that
together a little bit.
And then I'm gonna tear up some
mint leaves to go inside it.
- And now, I'm just gonna make
my mushroom and spinach concoction.
So I just put some olive oil in here,
adding my garlic and onions in first.
And so then I'll add in my
mushrooms and my spinach
and a little bit of salt.
A trick is once you can start
actually smelling the garlic,
that's when you know
that you should start adding
your other ingredients.
Now I'm gonna add in my spinach.
I'd just do like a quick little handful.
I'll add more if I want to.
- Now we're gonna do some
lime juice, cilantro.
Do you like cilantro?
- I'm not a fan.
- This is why I'm worried.
Cause it can be like an alienating thing
'cause some people, I think genetically,
it takes like soap right?
- Yeah.
And then I'm gonna do some garlic in it.
Mix this guy together.
I'm going through very like creamy texture
that can put in a squeeze bottle
and it's not gonna get like
stuck or lumpy in there.
- Now I'm gonna be trying
my sauce, my fig sauce.
Would you like to try?
- I'd love to try.
- Okay.
And tell me what it needs,
if it needs anything.
- I'm sure it's gonna be great.
Ooh, that's good.
- Thank you.
- Okay. Yeah.
Is it okay? Is it good?
- Holy cow, that's so good.
I don't think I was gonna
like there's cilantro in it.
- Oh right.
Okay. You're not kidding?
- I'm not getting soap. Don't worry.
- Okay, great. I'm gonna cry.
That makes me so happy.
So I'm gonna take my avocado crema
and put it into a squeeze ball.
- Potatoes are looking good.
So now we're gonna start
seasoning my filets.
So I'm just gonna do a
generous amount of salt,
a generous amount of garlic powder,
and then some pepper.
And then I'm gonna put it on here
and then I'll season it
when it's in the pan on the other side.
- Well I'm gonna grill up some pineapple.
I'm going for like kind
of al pastor flavors.
- [Producer] Do you think
there will be any brits
that make the invite list?
- Adele's gonna be there.
Oh, we forgot about Adele.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
Do you think she'll make a song for us?
- I think so.
(Katie singing)
- So that's my Adele impression.
- Okay.
- So it was like if I have kids,
is that embarrassing to do?
Something like that?
- My mom used to do that all the time.
Singing, showing funny videos
- Showing silly stuff.
- to my elementary school
crush of me as a baby.
Me and him never worked out.
- Look at that nice sear on those steaks.
- I'm gonna resear it too, because
- You want a little more
- Yeah.
- even.
(Katie gasps)
And I like really want some like dark,
almost like charred bits.
- I'm just looking for that
nice, dark brownish color.
And then I'm gonna baste it.
- The Instant Pot just finished,
so I'm gonna release the pressure.
(pressure cooker whistling)
- Wow.
- Pull out the pepper,
turning the saute on
cause I wanted to reduce
some of the liquid down
and I'm gonna start shredding
the pork with my two forks.
- I'll add in my butter and
I'm gonna start basting it.
Basting is just when you
like lock in all the flavors.
You just pretty much go like this.
You could add some herbs if you want to.
- I feel like we're really in
the heat of competition now.
- Yeah.
But when you're cooking at a dinner party,
you gotta be pretty precise.
And you always wanna be
just like a little nervous
because then if you're not
and you're too relaxed,
then you'll forget things and mess up.
Just try to have fun.
- I love people coming in
and making sure they get a drink,
whatever it is,
- Yeah.
- then maybe they can
it like a little snack.
- I love making fun little mocktails.
- Oh yeah. I have cocktails.
So like grown up.
I'm just trying to get
some color on my tortillas.
- Grinding out my fig apricot sauce.
I have everything ready.
So now I'm just gonna
try and take these out.
- I think it might be
cool for my tortillas
to be perfectly round.
- Yeah. I think that's pretty neat.
- So I'm gonna cut them
just a little bit smaller.
- Now we're gonna add in our mixture.
So now, I'm just gonna start assembling
with these different fruits.
- Slice up just very tiny
little bits of pineapple.
I'm getting too quiet
cause I'm so focused.
- I know. Me too.
- It's hard.
- I wanna talk, but it's
just like I'm in the zone.
I don't wanna add too much but
I don't wanna add too little.
- Yeah.
- Wanna leave anything on the floor.
- Sure. The floor.
- You don't wanna leave anything out.
- [Producer] On the field.
- On the field. Thank you.
- On the field. On the field.
- Yeah. That's a good one.
- You don't wanna leave
anything on the field.
- [Producer] I think you wanna
leave everything on the field
You wanna leave everything on the field?
- [Producer] Yeah.
- Sure.
- You don't wanna not leave
something on the field.
You need things on the field.
Yours this looking beautiful.
- Thanks.
- Oh my god.
Yeah. I'm feeling a
little nervous right now.
- I'm feeling nervous too. Don't Worry.
I'm gonna grab some of my pork now.
I'm just shake it off a little.
- I'm going to get some
mashed potatoes on here.
- Gonna put my crema on top.
- Add my filet on the bed of mashed.
So I'm gonna add my
spinach and mushroom mix.
You never know how the judge is gonna be.
- Jenn Harris is back.
She is one of the top food
writers in the country.
I'm really hoping to impress her.
I'm gonna add my pickled onions now.
- Basically I like adding a
lot of height to my dishes.
I definitely hope I can impress her again.
- Overall, I'm just trying to
make sure you get a mouthful
of every part of that I want you to taste.
She just to have judge,
she doesn't pull punches.
- Now I'm gonna do the sauce.
Pretty nervous for this part
because this could
either make or break it.
This is the fig cranberry sauce.
- I'm doing some cilantro
microgreens here.
- I'm just gonna clean up my dish.
You literally eat with your eyes first.
So just always try and have a clean dish.
- Everything's set, which
I'm very happy about.
So I'm just adding the strawberries
and some of the juice of the strawberry.
Okay. Flower, flower.
You gotta have the
prettiest flower on there.
You are not ready.
Why is this so hard for me?
Maybe I lose the flower.
No, I go flower.
Too many things are happening.
There's one flower.
I'm just getting one flower.
- I think hers looks really nice.
I'm scared.
- I need a flatter flower.
Put one with height.
You know what I'm talking about?
All right.
I'm happy with my entree.
- Me too.
- And my dessert.
Yours looks gorgeous. My god.
- Thanks. So does yours.
- And we're gonna give these to Jenn next.
- Yeah.
- Hopefully she likes them.
How are you feeling?
- So far, with my dishes I'm
both feeling pretty good,
but Jenn's a really serious
food critic slash judge.
- Yeah.
- So I'm a little nervous,
but I think we got this.
- That's good.
- I think we both killed it.
So let's just see what Jenn thinks.
- I'm Jenn Harris and I'm a
food columnist for the LA Times.
Once again, I'll be judging
Katie and Malia's competition.
So high end party food should be something
that you wouldn't typically
cook for yourself at home.
So it should feel special.
It should fill you up,
but not be too filling.
And it should be Instagram-friendly
cause you definitely wanna
take a picture of it.
I'll be giving each
entree a score of 1 to 5.
Also I'll be giving each
dessert a score of 1 to 5.
So the best total score
you can get is a 10.
I have high expectations
for both Katie and Malia.
I think they're extremely talented
and I cannot wait to
see what they cook up.
Let's start with the entrees.
I have no idea which one of you made what?
There is clearly a taco situation
and a nice piece of meat.
Clearly one is more
like a traditional take
on a fancy dinner,
and a newer take on what
might be considered fancy.
I wanna try the taco first.
That was a whole lot of flavor.
There's a really nice
sauce and marinade in there
with some like good heat to it.
The pineapple is like a
really nice sweet kick
with the onion.
There's some sort of creamy avocado sauce.
There's like nice acid in there.
It tastes like al pastor taco
you would have at a
fabulous food truck in LA.
Very impressed with this.
Also presentation,
this looks very nice and definitely fancy.
That is also delicious.
And the meat is cooked perfectly.
The mashed potatoes are a
really nice fluffy texture
and it's kind of like what
you'd get at a steakhouse.
They're both delicious
but I have to give like a half extra point
to this person for the plating.
So I'm gonna give this a 4.5,
and this one, a four.
Let's try the desserts.
I'll try the purple one first.
I do like the color.
Okay. Let me get a little
bit of everything in here.
Okay.
When I do eat dessert,
I want there to be a lot to mine there
and to have a bunch of
different textures and flavors.
So this is nice in that each bite
you kind of get something
a little bit different.
And this is something nice
and light and refreshing
after the tacos.
So this pairs nicely with it.
All right. I'm gonna to try the tart now.
Also nice because there's
some citrus in the cream
so it's not too heavy.
It's baked well.
I kinda just taste like
a good butter cookie.
I honestly feel like both
exceeded and met the challenge.
So please invite me to
the party, by the way.
This is difficult.
I am going to give this
dessert a four and a half.
This dessert is also very good.
I'm gonna give this dessert a four.
Okay. We have a winner.
I don't know for the winner is.
- It's me.
I was so blessed. It was so close.
(group clapping)
I won finally.
Finally.
I needed it.
We have both won now.
- Congratulations, Katie.
You definitely deserved it.
I did win last time.
So it is only fair that she won this time.
- I think Malia in is inspirational.
I was really worried
that she would feel
like a different person
when we saw each other two years later.
But it just felt like we
picked up where we left off.
Seeing someone her age just
be so secure and so sweet.
It is inspiring.
- I just feel like we just get each other.
Katie's her old same self,
like super sweet, super
loving and super funny.
And I just love hanging
out and cooking with her.
The next time, I'm definitely
coming back for that win.
(groovy jazz music)